ciao a tutti benvenuti a un nuovo
esperimento su che succederà a 9 partito
ciao a tutti benvenuti al 9 esperimento
su questo canale che si chiama qwerty la
tastiera senza auto correct che ti
costringe ad assumerti la responsabilità
di tutto quello che scrivi con un'unica
differenza che qua si esce con la
coscienza pulita perché perché le
conversazioni sono le vostre ma
rispondere sono io
partiamo subito perché non vedo a
ricominciare scusatemi per il nubifragio
che c'è fuori
partiamo del giorno il primo commento e
ciao io vado con lasciato i soldi per il
disturbo sul tavolo rai2 pizzette nella
cucina grazie per avermi ospitato dietro
il divano c'è una bottiglia da 0,5 litri
l'ho usata per fare pipì nel mezzo della
notte per evitare di fare mores degli
arti mi sono dimenticato di buttarci per
che cosa dire allora grazie per il
pensiero la prossima volta se puoi
arrecare meno disturbo potresti berla se
poi vuoi fare il signore non chiedermi
ma è più di ospitarti ps grazie per le
pizzette sei stata al pride no purtroppo
quest'anno no perché perché non è una
cosa mi piace il padre preso a
ventilatore questa chat vale tutto mamma
sono incinta affettato carote alla
julienne al o chi si prende a stomaco
vuoto stomaco pieno qual è il
significato dei ragni dei sogni ma un
giardino c'è un uomo morto ciao chi sei
ho fatto un numero per scrivere
conoscere persone cambiare due parole
vedo parole ma che sta giocando a
scarabeo questo come con facebook ma
visto che io non ho facebook ho provato
qui spero di non disturbarli questo deve
comprare veramente una vocale ragazze a
cambiare due parole scrivono shaper
cambiare due consonanti lista scattata
la indovina una ho allora averlo meno
tratta la normale che è l'unica persona
intelligente e brava di quella casa e te
sei falsa come con quello che dici non
sei quello che credi cioè una persona
coerente con quello che dice in questo
caso mi cosparge il capo di cenere
ha ragione io
mai stata coerente per atteggiamento
falla mettiamo fallo ma io quest uomo lo
sa e non mi sento da perderlo o io
continuerei con questi pollici il suo
all'infinito voglio vedere chi demorde
prima innamorato sempre di più in fondo
all'anima tutto ok amore che amo ti amo
ti amo e lui la curva sorda io ho
mettere direttamente single su facebook
ciao ciao ciao 30 aprile il mio 15
questa cosa va avanti da anni 30 mila
2015 ciao 19 maggio 2015 e il 3 dicembre
2015 fattori febbraio 2016 ciao 18
febbraio 2016 alle 11 e 27 scrive a ciao
cupido mi ha lasciato in prestito una
freccia posso usarla contro di te no
grazie
la freccia mettila per segnalare alle
altre macchine la tua svolta a destra
contro il guard rail sono io quello che
madonna che bono tu sei la classica
scontata e carina banale rivedibile
capisci sono troppo bello e tu sei sì
insomma te la cavi un po di trucco e si
dai puoi andare essi dai una busta di
carta in testa e le spalle e mezzo al
buio della foresta sotto sotto potete
pure dirtelo che sei carina ma chi era
tse gun che ti ho scritto questo qui
come minimo da esse brad pitt col
cervello di un colibrì le ha risposto ma
muori carina sarà la tua maglietta ma
assenti l'ocarina questo caso devo dire
che hai sbagliato in questi casi non si
scrive un messaggio in questi casi si
agisce prendi una lacca prendi un
accendino e non gli fai la messa in
piega i file direttamente una messa in
chiesa ciao scusa mi disturba o mi
chiamo hicks posso farti una domanda
insolita wi fi problemi e per testare
gli insetti
vi spiego il motivo della domanda sono
interessato a conoscere le reazioni
delle persone a certi temi a livello
amatoriale dalle risposte e dalle
reazioni dover comprendere una persona o
sofferti altre domande simili che si
basano sulle reazioni agli insetti
animali vari ciao giovane entomologa
che tipo di l'urbe erotiche ai
esattamente comunque per risponderti
preferirei schiacciare con la lingua un
cesto di taranto le che calpestare la
mia dignità facendo domande simile alla
gente se vuoi preoccuparti di un insetto
preoccupati di quello che tieni nelle
mutande e un po troppo forte la bestia
inviate parlando con una persona che ha
sognato di avere succo di frutta al
posto del sangue vuoi cambiare argomento
a caso e andrà bene come succo di frutta
e immaginari persone e fatti perché
stavo pensando ai vampiri per non mi
ricordo quale motivo ho pensato che ne
umani se teniamo il nostro sangue non ce
ne facciamo niente se invece fosse ricco
di frutta non sarebbe una gran figata
caro edward succo di frutta a parte come
è stato verso il cervello
ehi ciao scusa il disturbo ti ho vista
in giro ogni tanto e ti trovo una bella
ragazza che avevo due piccole domande
era un dom
accetteresti mai un invito per un caffè
da uno sconosciuto se la risposta è no
la seconda domanda secondo te esiste un
modo per cancellare la memoria spero di
sì o questa figura di merda non la
dimentico carissimo casanova no non
esiste un modo per cancellare la memoria
ma esiste un modo per cancellarsi da
facebook 9 se cattiva se vuoi il caffè
lo prendiamo ognuno a casa sua numerino
perché in realtà è stato simpatico ma in
giro averlo letto non glielo vogliamo
proprio dare una chance a questo povero
ragazzo
no direi di no ali arrivo mi è venuto un
attacco di a mi è venuto un attacco di
aerei in pancia gastrite e devo fare un
po d'aria per sgonfiare la pancia ok ma
poi tutti questa persona è solo il
numero cioè vuol dire che non è tua
amica e rispondiamo subito tranquilla
scoraggiati pure l'anima io ti aspetto
in piazza sono quella con la tuta
maro hicks lo so che non è un buon
momento visto che ti sei appena lasciata
poco ho paura già continuare ma nella
vita ci sono delle occasioni che non
bisogna perdere e penso che questa sia
una di quelle ora penso ancora come
quest'estate e volevo sapere se quando
te la senti rai di riniziare una storia
avrò ancora delle possibilità per
stanzialmente un po in ginocchio è vero
nella vita ci sono occasioni che non
bisogna lasciarsi sfuggire tipo tacere
purtroppo io non la penso come questa
estate la penso come tua madre non era
meglio fermarsi a uno di figlio che
questo messaggio arrivato un minimo di
preambolo allora ciao
ecco un messaggio a cui non ho
minimamente risposto di mio ex che mi ha
lasciato mesi fa spezzando nel cuore
mille piccoli frammenti appena saputo
che mi sono rifatto una vita mi ha
mandato questo bellissimo sms usando il
nomignolo che tanto odiavo dovrei
scriverti per esprimere il mio disprezzo
nei tuoi confronti ma ho tirato un
respiro di ho deciso che la persona a
cui ho dedicato più di un anno della mia
preziosa vita non voglio lasciare un
insulto ma un consiglio smettila di
strisciare come il verme che sei stata
per 26 anni grazie per una volta prova
ad alzare la testa ea camminare con le
sue gambe diventa una donna con la d
maiuscola e smettila di arrecare
vergogna al tuo sesso starei meglio fare
stare meglio le persone intorno a te
magari che questa volta otterrà il
rispetto di qualcuno buonanotte selle
ciao caro che bello sentirti ho lasciato
un dietro di ammoniaca nel mobiletto del
bagno nutrite ne è con questo siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video
fatemi sapere se questo esperimento vi è
piaciuto o magari se avete di consigli
per le persone che mi hanno mandato
nelle loro conversazioni io vi invito a
iscrivervi a questo canale se non volete
perdervi nulla attivare le notifiche
fare quelle cose i like senso niente vi
mando un bacio e vi do un appuntamento
alla prossima settimana